welcome to this video valvoline from
Brazil Louis aleksandra from Belo
Horizonte okay I have a bad score
against the sky oops one win two losses
do we get the bank of gambit it's
playing a completely incorrect version
of this gambit but let's see how it's
how it continues let's see a for I can
start with a forever one time h3 is also
good hoping for Bishop a six no is
putting the night down okay well I can
go to e2 on yeah it's okay just develop
yeah in this version of the bank of
black is just a pawn down for absolutely
no compensation whatsoever so it's one
of those lines where you feel badly as
white if you don't win because they just
give you a pawn for nothing his counter
play is just far far slower in
comparison to two other bingo forms
because I just I just could castle and
the normal Benko it doesn't what okay
doesn't happen like that it just killed
his own bishop for this for this for the
smooth okay so let's see can take a6
could be three at the night f3 looks a
bit it looks a bit awkward can also just
take here and may this is a simplest way
to play his Bishop is now dead on g7 so
it's a bit difficult to grasp at least
he had some some kind of activity when
he had the bishop open on the long
diagonal
okay so Bishop chinks this is probably
probably the best see takes rook takes
wins the piece right away and so far mmm
this might also lead to problems for him
I can prepare the move aid form and it's
hard to prevent root K 3 Bishop see one
okay so a for intends to take can still
play it
c4 hangsen so many many attractive
options yeah come on let's do it don't
want to get into huge drying time
pressure after this the way this game
unfolded the easiest now would be to get
in Quincy six and then March the beep on
ok B and C porn ideally
yeah note that he plays without this
bishop on f6 this could easily be a pawn
it's just amounts to the same thing this
is the consequence of playing our six ok
f3 so that I can move the beep on that's
probably probably easiest and I just
want to cover you form come on your
phone to mamby maybe Bishop to g3 then
yeah hmm I wonder could also just I
can't allow the trade it's not like this
is terrible to allow it is rook a one
okay okay let's allow this it's not
really great yeah maybe a freezing the
best possible way to go check but I
still have the beep on this is some this
is the main of the main problem here and
it's supported by the rook so be 54 look
see to first Roxy to rocks is seven
okay so he allows me be five rupee six
books c6 that's surprising that that I
can go all the way to be six ok now this
and the King now up to to be five that
should be the end of it check so we
could be three I can I can take time
here check
King to be five and then shall you see
seven
there's really no defense at least i
hope i have no overlooked something
stupid rook c7 will come and then I'm
invading
yeah be 7 next door after the trade and
promoting the look on v3 is always
covering the base of my chain on f3 so
there is no count to play with the king
yeah now it's taking time that's a bit
late
getting the clock run down
that's not very exciting okay black
resign yeah now we resigned yeah and
this was really important that to see if
you if you play the banker gambit like
that yes black you definitely should
yeah should you should do one of the
following let's say Bishop a6 is of
course the normal the normal movement
and this is the wood main line which
nowadays is a slightly tricky tricky
thing because white has some good ideas
with them with this this is considered
to be a problem in the Banco benco main
line and therefore people have started
to experiment I think it is Queen a five
in this position that's a new idea
simply to to get to something then Co
style but not the precise position that
I just just just have shown and the
point of this move is to just prevent d
form so that you 494 is ridiculous oh so
white has to develop in some way and
then we get a new position it's it's not
that that much explore to this some this
position after the six however this is
just a mistake because I go e form and
now I don't have to do this King journey
here I just can develop now and here
this is really just a pawn down for
nothing and very often people play those
structures and to think they have a they
have some compensation I don't know for
for for what yeah yeah they are the open
lines but you also have to have some
pieces there to actually put pressure
and here there is simply nothing going
on on the queenside I just have a pawn
here and when f6 s is unspeakable I
really don't know what to say it is just
the least the least playable move ever
in this position I know that if ye five
is an issue but when you play a six you
might as well resign because you kill
your own bishop
and I could have probably made it far
more far more convincing if I am somehow
could have avoided this um this is
Bishop trade and maybe I'm can play
better here Luke c1 or something I mean
this kept kept a decisive edge that
that's clear but if 3am maybe maybe add
if I spend spend some time here I can
maybe try to i can go b5 actually like
this b7 and so on he cannot even take
their so okay I should have calculated T
and go be five this is much stronger
than because well if I get there this is
a dead piece and I'm covering this very
nicely f3 allowed him to to get in there
and check this is still excellent for we
but it's nothing nothing special anymore
but we can go look be 8 by the way what
did he do actually I even for this okay
i had just lose the Bonilla wow I played
this like an idiot Bishop f2 that was
terrible ha I have to do this then I was
irritated by this move but of course I
can just do here now wow so if you could
have completely equalized here and said
you played this check and now it's it's
it's it's better again for me I mean
probably winning probably winning with
the beep horn hmm right then f3 was
really bad in combination with the mover
right after that okay well thanks for
watching